when i say like i was going to be top
biller i was going to build a million
like in 2019 i said to the guys i'm
going to be a million this year and
they're like no you're not like crazy
it's great i had complete belief i knew
i was going to do it how do you think
people can cultivate more
self-confidence and self-belief do you
think self-confidence i wish i knew i'm
not a confident person i doubt myself a
lot really and i think that is probably
what drives me on because i don't know
how i'm doing what i'm doing like i like
i wish i could like give a blueprint to
our current team like guys this is
exactly what to do it's exactly what to
say but i think it's that fear of this
could stop at any moment yeah i'm not
going to let it like i'm not going to
take my foot off the gas it's the
momentum that's got me here and i'm
going to keep on like i could probably
i've taken like 10 holidays in my entire
career like from back at the golf course
all the way to this date now you know
yeah i've never i've never stopped
[Music]